[Music]
Donald Trump added the Washington Post
to the list of news organizations that
are banned from his campaign events
he just bans news organizations
apparently Trump is angry with how the
Washington Post has been covering his
campaign now this means there are now 12
this is real 12 news organizations
banned from Trump events to listen clewd
The Washington Post
Gawker BuzzFeed foreign policy Politico
fusion Univision Mother Jones the New
Hampshire union-leader
the Des Moines Register The Daily Beast
and Huffington Post all banned from
covering Donald Trump now there's still
quite a few news organizations that are
allowed into Trump events for example
there's Fox News there's The Washington
Times there's foreign bride aficionado
there's the fantastic news you're gonna
Blu love me believe me Korea there's the
website truck nuts dotnet slash politics
there's good housekeepers magazine
there's the wall to keep out Mexican
Street Journal there's Gary Busey's
tumblr page
and finally small handed douches with
yachts magazine
you
you